لا استثناء سواء في ام درمان او في ولايات
ومدن السودان الاخرى عمليات سرقه ونهب لم
تفرق بين محله تجاريه او مقر حكوميه
هنا في سوق ام درمان الرئيسي يعيش التجار
ورواد السوق حاله من الهلع والالم بعد
انتشار عمليات النهب التي طالت غالبيه
المتاجر في حين تعرضت اخرى لحرق كامل
بعد الساعه عشره المحل مكسور وما في اي
حاجه
من اولها لاخر هذه او لا
واقع مر حل بغالبيه المدن السودانيه فمنذ
بدء الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع
منتصف ابريل الماضي لم تتوقف عمليات
السرقه وسط اتهامات متبادله بين طرفي
الصراع وعجز الشرطه عن تامين الاسواق
والمراكز الحكوميه بل وحتى المنازل
عمليات النهب والتخريب هذه القت بظلالها
ايضا على مؤسسات الدوله بما فيها الخدميه
والصحيه اذ شهدت وزاره التربيه والتعليم
بجنوب دارفور عمليات تخريب شملت حرقا
كاملا لمخازن الوزاره ومطابع الامتحانات
الوحيده التي تقدم الخدمات ايضا لولايتي
شرق ووسط دارفور المؤسف ايضا تم حرق كل
المطابع بتاعتنا التي نطبع بها الامتحانات
التي نضع بها الامتحانات للمراحل المختلفه
وبنضع بها ايضا لاخواننا في وسط دارفور
بها لاخواننا في شرق دارفور حادثه من بين
مجموعه حلت بالسودانيين كانت وراء تعليق
ولايه جنوب دارفور العام الدراسي واغلاق
المدارس لاجل غير مسمى وهو من عكس على
حياه السودانيين فلا خدمات سواء صحيه او
تعليميه فيما يعجز التجار عن تقدير حتى
خسائرهم الفادحه نتيجه النهب ويبقى
المواطن السوداني اسيرا لكل هذه الازمات